powerful suicide bomb being targeted
south or in Zabul province this morning
killing at least 20 people according to
the local provincial council members
Taliban claimed responsibility for this
attack claiming that they have targeted
the local intelligence compound but also
a local hospital was damaged and many
people have been killed and wounded
there so the local official said that
they tried to transfer as many as they
could to the neighbouring province of
Kandahar this is happening while they
talks between the US and the Taliban has
halted and stopped and the fighting
between these two groups I mean the
government and the Taliban has
intensified in different levels in front
lines as well as in the cities and in
the outskirts especially in the
districts so we had heard another
incident deadly incident that happened
in eastern part of Afghanistan that
us-backed Afghan forces targeted a group
of farmers that were there for
harvesting point nets and according to
the local officials around 30 people
have been killed and local governor
office saying that they have transferred
nine dead bodies and six wounded to the
local hospital the local provincial
governor office announced that their
target was - militants
you